[Música]
bom dia a todos
eu vim aqui contar pra vocês que eu
quase morri e aí eu descobri uma fonte
de felicidade um caminho para ter
felicidade é tudo começou com um
mal-estar né eu tinha feito uma bateria
de exames recente estava com a saúde o
que estava tudo certo mas de repente eu
comecei a passar mal e eu não sabia o
que estava acontecendo e eu comecei a
investigar
comecei a buscar porque aquilo estava
acontecendo e foi por uma bateria de
exames bem profunda em dez dias
entre o início de um mal estar que
parecia uma gripe ea confirmação do
diagnóstico eu descobri uma leucemia é
era uma leucemia do tipo mielóide aguda
e qualquer diferença dessa para os
outros tipos de leucemia que nem sabia
que existiam tantos né
ela é profunda agressiva extremamente
agressiva e se instala muito rápido e o
que foi o primeiro aprendizado dessa
história né
ou você faz logo o que você tem que
fazer
você não tem mais tempo e aí eu fui pro
hospital iniciar um tratamento que
demoraria sete meses em tratamento
extremamente agressivo também porque
contra uma doença como essa não tem água
com açúcar
e aí eu comecei em tentar entender
porque aquilo estava acontecendo comigo
eu nunca questionei a doença nunca
questionei porque comigo eu sempre
questionei o que eu devo aprender com
isso né eu acredito que a gente passa
pelas coisas na vida da gente tanto as
boas quanto as não tão boas para evoluir
para aprender e para melhorar e para
mudar o ambiente onde a gente está
inserido e aí tentei buscar o propósito
disso
bom eu sempre tive vontade de me dedicar
o voluntariado nessa vontade de fazer
parte da cidade
é de jaraguá do sul tem uma força muito
grande nisso e eu queria participar de
alguma maneira mas a agenda de trabalho
nunca me permitiu trabalhava numa
empresa na área corporativa e nunca
consegui me dedicar a isso né
bom como esses pensamentos que eu tive
tempo de de construir eu resolvi que
aquilo seria um propósito
se eu saísse vivo daquela história eu
queria me dedicar a isso iria colaborar
para que eu pudesse transformar um
pedacinho das coisas ao meu redor
para melhor e aí me tratei até o final
do objetivo do do tratamento agarrado a
esse objetivo
volto pra empresa depois dos 7 anos e aí
mais uma surpresa eu fui convidado para
assumir não uma mas duas diretorias
naquele momento que era de marketing e
produto raio disse bohn mais um desafio
vamos lá né aquilo por vários motivos eu
precisava assumir eu queria sumir era um
reconhecimento do trabalho
mas o meu propósito continuava firme e
ele determine um prazo para isso tudo
muito bom
durante cinco anos eu vou trabalhar vou
construir essa história aqui dentro da
empresa e depois eu vou tocar o meu
planejamento próprio e me dedicar ao
voluntariado 3 que eu me programei para
fazer naquele momento tive todo o apoio
que precisava naquele momento para isso
e seguir em frente
bom enquanto isto acontecia eu comecei a
me aproximar do voluntariado aqui em
jaraguá por meio de um trabalho que era
feito num dos nossos hospitais e por
meio de um amigo que trabalhava num
grupo de palhaços
aí galera veio o primeiro choque de
realidade
eu percebi que não tinha graça nenhuma
como é que eu ia colaborar com aquilo se
eu era um palhaço sem graça né
mas eu só que vamos adiante vamos
entender então o que acontece aqui como
é que essas pessoas trabalham realizando
essa essa jornada aqui pra saber como é
que eu poderia colaborar e aí eu tive
mais uma surpresa
a gente muitas vezes por não estar
conectado
a dor não está é realmente focado
naquilo que é o nosso propósito a gente
perde muitas informações e eu tive a
surpresa de entender que existia 115
pessoas naquilo naquela organização já
trabalhando algumas há três décadas
a gente trabalha 30 desculpa há 30 anos
lá da mesma maneira como eu queria
começar naquele momento né
e aí eu iniciei o trabalho dentro de uma
comissão interna no hospital
para entender como é que aquilo tudo
funcionava e para colaborar com aquilo
que eu tinha para entregar que a
experiência em gestão e marketing
então durante 13 anos durante três anos
nós preparamos todo o trabalho de
organização dos grupos de organização do
trabalho interno de constituição de uma
organização maior pra que para melhorar
a apresentação do que era feito pra
gente buscar novos grupos novas pessoas
buscar recursos para aquilo que
acontecia e ampliar o trabalho para mais
acções né
e esse envolvimento todo aconteceu
também no período em que houve aqui em
jaraguá do sul um encontro de
voluntários da saúde esse encontro
acontece todos os anos em alguma cidade
do estado e naquele ano aconteceu aqui
em jaraguá
e aí veio de lá uma ideia de trazer pra
cá uma casa porque foi apresentada essa
esse case de uma casa de apoio a um
hospital da cidade de xanxerê que traz
uma casa é perto do hospital para
acolher pacientes de hóspedes que vão lá
e ficam quando não têm condições de
pagar pela hospedagem ficam nessa casa
enquanto tratamento acontece a gente
expor vão lá como é que a gente faz isso
em jaraguá
como é que a gente traz isso pra cá
quando a gente pode melhorar esse mundo
aqui também como é que a gente consegue
fazer isso
bom a nossa vontade é do que uma casa
pequena que não fosse muito longe do
hospital para não gerar custos de
transporte que não fosse muito grande
para não ter muito custo
se conseguisse atender as pessoas que
passassem por ali com nossa ação
voluntária
quer dizer só de pessoas que tenham
vontade mas não tem dinheiro a gente tem
dinheiro pra nada naquele momento e não
sabe ainda onde eu consegui
é isso aí o que acontece
vocação voluntária em jaraguá do sul é
fantástico gente vocês realmente
precisam entender que a nossa cidade
inclusive foi construída em muitas
situações por essa vontade voluntária
pelas são de voluntários na sua história
inteira
a gente tem diversos é grupos atuando na
cidade com muita gente participando e
assim é é de verdade muito bom falar
sobre isso para que a gente consiga
inclusive trazer mais gente para buscar
outras ações que tem muita coisa para
ser feita
bom a gente tem também uma série de bem
feitores na cidade que apóiam as causas
quando elas são honestas e transparentes
e bem encaminhadas e aí eu fui entender
um pouquinho disso em povo olhando para
a própria história do hospital 1926 um
grupo de chofer se que transportava
pessoas de jaraguá para joinville porque
aqui a gente não tinha hospital tomou a
iniciativa de voluntariamente formar um
grupo para constituir uma em uma
associação que formaria e contraria o
primeiro hospital aqui
ele foi construído aqui no shea neves em
1936 ele foi inaugurado depois ele
passou pelo centro da cidade em 1959 em
uma sede mais próxima da igreja porque a
igreja que administrava na época o
hospital
todos esses projetos tiveram uma força
muito grande dos voluntários em 1980
1980 há mais de 30 anos surgiu
internamente o primeiro dos grupos que
hoje ainda trabalha lá
nós temos pessoas que trabalham há quase
40 anos no hospital
isso é muito forte quando eu me deparei
com isso disse onde estava o tempo todo
que eu não fui antes participar dos
projetos
em 2004 uma grande mobilização é da
cidade dos empresários da cidade passou
a
a aacc hospital como uma forma de dar
continuidade ao trabalho das irmãs da
divina providência que na época
trabalhava nesse projeto e que não tinha
mais condições para isso
então houve uma mudança muito grande
desse desse trabalho interno e quando
tudo estava numa conclusão é por ocasião
dos 80 anos do hospital da comemoração
dos 80 anos do hospital houve uma
cerimônia e eu contei essa história
inteira pra dizer que nessa cerimônia a
gente teve uma grande surpresa
essa cerimônia aconteceu dois meses e
meio depois da nossa idéia de constituir
uma casa aqui em jaraguá
o empresário da cidade cedeu a casa dele
a uma quadra do hospital com 15 quartos
com 24 leitos disponíveis em uma área de
500 metros quadrados para a gente montar
o projeto da casa são josé
aquilo foi uma alegria monstra né
a vontade de ter alguma coisa pequena se
transformada transformava de repente uma
coisa fantástica
no minuto seguinte o desespero a gente
não tinha como colher dentro da casa
a gente recebeu uma casa reformada com
tudo que precisava inclusive ar
condicionado em todos os quartos tudo
fantástico sem uma colher e agente que a
gente vai fazer agora né a gente
entendeu vamos la vida desafios mais um
né ea gente se inspirou num projecto que
aconteceu nos estados unidos por ocasião
do furacão katrina onde um grupo de
varejistas e eu e uma comunicadora muito
importante nos estados unidos se unirão
construir um site é como casas virtuais
e que as pessoas podiam ir lá e comprar
a colher ou a casa com problemas
pudessem colaborar
a gente se assim a gente vamos trazer
isso aqui pra guarda como é que a gente
faz isso aqui em jaraguá
a gente tem possibilidade disso já que a
gente tem uma vocação voluntário é muito
grande
vou montar um show na casa com tudo o
que precisa
olhando para os varejistas locais pedi
para que eles nos ajudem a organizar
isso vender isso tudo
unidade convidando a para conhecer o
projeto e colaborar como 10 ea gente fez
isso apresentamos foi um por um
varejista aqui do estado e ele disse ok
eu vou colaborar com isso me esperem uma
da maneira como vocês é precisarem agora
é organizar o processo
envie pra mim uma lista de necessidades
e eu vou colaborar
bom vamos pra casa a gente assim ó gente
vai vender certo a gente vai convidar as
pessoas para comprar a galera lista da
noiva dos sonhos
a gente tem que entregar a melhor lista
tão 24 leitos 48 itens de tudo roupa de
cama louça talheres todos os
eletrodomésticos tudo o que se puder
imaginar para montar uma casa para
atender 24 pessoas
enviamos a lista pra eles e ficamos
esperando duas semanas depois ele ligou
um dia à noite e diz o seguinte olha não
vai mais aconteceu
o bazar aí né meu mundo caiu disse poxa
mas o que aconteceu é que a gente vai
doar tudo pra casa
a gente decidiu que a gente vai
colaborar e doar todos os itens que
vocês colocaram na lista de vocês
e aí gente nessa hora a sensação de
estar no caminho certo né de entender
que as pessoas realmente quando vêem um
projeto é coordenado com seriedade e com
vontade de ajudar os outros é isso muda
as coisas e isso potencializa as ações
ea gente se vê na frente de uma casa
linda reformada toda pronta com o
caminhão de mudanças descarregando tudo
e assim nasce a casa são josé
a gente tem naquele momento também uma
necessidade de organização para a
administração daquilo que a gente
precisava é organizar o processo
inclusive juridicamente e constituímos
associação de voluntários de são josé
que tem o lema do meu coração é
voluntário
a gente leva isso para todo mundo
partilhar com a gente e naquele momento
eu fui convidado para ser presidente da
associação de voluntários e aí eu
entendi mais uma vez que estava no
caminho certo
a dor de nove anos antes agora está
completando 19 anos essa situação e
silenciou estava dando lugar para esse
momento de realização realmente de um
projeto bacana e assim a gente iniciou o
tratamento
o o o trabalho na casa
hoje nós somos 300 voluntários em nove
grupos têm mais quatro sendo
constituídos
a casa já atendeu 883 pessoas em 7.046
diárias
quer dizer o número de pessoas versus o
número de tempo que fica na casa
às vezes ficam dia às vezes fica 50 dias
dependendo da necessidade
tudo é gratuito nós já entregamos 16 mil
e 600 refeições nesse período ea gente
recebeu formatando novamente aqui é é o
espírito de voluntariado da cidade nós
já recebemos 14,6 toneladas de alimentos
nesses dois anos e meio e podem ser
campanhas em empresas em eventos festas
que são organizadas as pessoas pedem
isso
como presente até como exemplo de uma
senhora e toda semana leva um pão
caseiro no portão da casa
ela diz que essa é a maneira como ela
consegue colaborar e elas entregam por
semana e aí a gente volta a perguntar se
está mesmo é que está a felicidade
andré que está a felicidade nisso tudo é
coisa que eu encontrei um caminho de
felicidade lá atrás
a felicidade está em cada doação que a
gente recebe no olhar de cada pessoa que
recebe atendimento na casa
os novos voluntários que nos procuram
para colaborar na possibilidade de estar
aqui representando tanta gente que
trabalha voluntariamente jaraguá do sul
isso é uma felicidade muito grande mas
eu quero ler pra vocês um pedaço de uma
carta porque nós temos um livro de
mensagens no hospital
é na casa são josé e ela fica lá
todas as pessoas que queiram escrevam
suas mensagens e são inúmeras e muito
bonitas e aqui a gente pode ler o resumo
do que acontece neste momento como
maravilhoso receber apoio em momentos de
necessidade
recebemos esse presente esse presente
uma cama limpinha em quarto o fresquinho
comidas para alimentar o corpo e mais e
mais
mas o mais lindo que todo esse presente
é a hora de amor e bondade que manda em
cada cantinho dessa casa
o acolhimento de cada trabalhador
foi marcante
um projeto como esse desperta muita
esperança na humanidade
saiu daqui uma pessoa melhor com uma
lição de fraternidade possível e
concretizável
eu fui acolhida no car no quarto
gratidão e esse é o sentimento que eu
levo comigo e que aqui também deixa é eu
digo pra vocês que esse tipo de mensagem
realmente faz sentido e cada vez que a
gente leva a mensagem disso a gente se
emociona muito
porque aí que a gente encontra a
felicidade que vem do outro e para
resumir pra vocês o sentimento dessa
história toda
hoje eu posso dizer quase dez anos
depois é que valeu muito a pena quase
ter morrido
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]